The brother please can I have your name
and your profession?
>> Uh my name's now my Muslim's name is
>> now is Jamal.
>> Jamal.
>> Yes. My Christian's name before Paul.
>> Okay. What's your profession?
>> Uh formerly I work in my church.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. And now uh I I bring al
me up from them.
>> Please speak in the mic brother. Please
speak in the mic. Volunteers. Okay, I
will ask only one question, one
questions. Okay,
>> go ahead. Uh, I have visited my uh
relative h my relative house three
times. Three times but was rejected.
Uh, I will ask what is the solutions?
Can you repeat your question? It is not
clear.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Uh, I'm a former Christians. Okay.
>> Okay. You're a former Christian.
>> Yeah. Uh, one and a half year maybe.
>> Okay. Uh could you speak louder please?
>> Okay. Um I will ask I have visited my
relative
uh house three times but was rejected.
>> Okay. You went to your relative house
three times or rejected?
>> Yeah. The question is what is the
solution? Uh according the Muslim law.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Including my my wife also
um she won't know me anymore.
Sorry your wife doesn't want to
I have I have uh uh
>> brother can you speak in the mic? You're
speaking half in the mic half outside.
>> Yeah.
>> So if you speak continue the break I can
hear you. So you may say I may hear half
and think something else.
>> Okay.
This only only one question I have I
have told you.
>> You told me that you went to your
relative house thrice and you were
rejected as 50 times.
>> What is the meaning of rejected? Did
they not allow you to enter the house or
they kicked you or reject means what?
>> Yes.
>> English wise rejected me. Did they not
allow you to enter the house?
>> Yes. Because I changed my religion. They
rejected all rejected me.
>> You went to your relative house
>> three times.
>> Three times.
>> Yes.
>> And they rejected you.
>> Rejected me.
>> That mean they didn't allow you to enter
the house?
>> No. No. Until now. No. No.
>> I asked what is the solution according
the Muslim Islam is
>> whether if I can understand your
English. Yes.
>> You said you were rejected. Rejected
means were you refused to enter the
house?
>> No. No. Because I I I changed my
origins. You know that's
>> I understand. You changed from
Christianity to Islam.
>> Yeah.
>> What is the meaning of reject? Did they
not allow you to come into the house or
did they not speak to you or did they
slap you? Did they hit you?
>> They won't uh knowing me anymore.
>> They don't want to talk to you.
>> Yes. That's right.
>> Okay. Who relative? relative is vast.
Are they your third cousin or first
cousin? Maybe your father. What is the
relationship between you and them? Then
I can answer better.
>> Yeah. My brother also all my families.
>> Ah,
>> according my wife.
>> Your brother and your wife.
>> All
>> your brother and your wife and they
reject you.
>> Yes. All my my family.
>> Oh. So your brother and your wife and
your other family members reject you.
Yes. So what is the solution?
>> Yes. for the delusion according to
Muslims according to Islam's
>> the solution brother is first I would
like to congratulate you that they have
come to the fold of Islam
>> yes that's right
>> congratulate you number two it's your
duty to give the message of Islam to
your other relatives your brother your
wife all of them it's your duty now how
well do you give the message is a point
to be noted what you have to do that you
have to be kind to them you have to be
loving to them. You should not get angry
at them. And with hikma, you have to
deliver the message of Islam.
So when you deliver the message, they
may be angry with you. If they get
angry, you do not retaliate. You be kind
with them. You give them some gifts.
Give them some chocolates.
Correct?
>> The more they retaliate, the more kind
you you should be with them because they
are.
Allah gave you haya. Now it's your job
that you should try and get them to the
fold of Islam.
>> So you should be very loving, very kind
and you can speak logically.
For example, you can ask them
that do they believe that Jesus is God?
>> Yes. So you have to ask them okay that
why do you believe Jesus is God?
So when you ask them they will reply
they will try and convince you about
Christianity. Correct.
>> Correct.
>> So if you see my video cassettes. Okay.
>> I've given the talk on similarities
between Islam and Christianity.
>> Yes.
>> Today I gave a talk on Mhamad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam in the world religion.
One part of my lecture was prophet
Muhammad in the Bible. Correct.
>> Correct. So if you can speak to them
that you read the Bible, Prophet
Muhammad is mentioned in the Bible, you
are supposed to follow the teachings of
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him. Why
don't you follow? So you have to put
them into a conversation but with hikma.
Sometime they may get angry, they may
retaliate. So you have to speak very
softly, lovingly with care. Maybe you
can give them my video cassettes.
You can give them my video cassette.
There are many of my video cassette
which have been translated to bahasa.
So if they know English it is good. If
they don't know you can give the basa
translation. The cassettes on similarity
Islam and Christianity mham sallallahu
alaihi wasallam in the Bible concept of
God in major religion misconception
about Islam. All these cassettes if you
give even if they retaliate you have to
be kind with them. You have to love
them. You are not sinful at all.
As long as you convey the message
whether they accept or not say not in
it's not in your hand but if you try
your level best to convince them you
will get your sab
hope that answers the question you'll
get your blessing
>> your blessings okay thank you
>> most welcome
>> so so they they they ask me why why you
choose Islam I have two reasons only two
first two chapter that's only in John 17
verse3 and Mark uh 12:29. I think you
know the first.
>> Yes.
>> So good. So you told them about that.
>> Uh uh Jesus said that we must uh worship
and believe uh the only one God.
>> Correct.
>> As is uh
>> yes that's my reasons. That's my reason.
Yeah.
>> Very good. So what did they reply? uh
they they replied
no we we can live uh in one house with
different religions so I move out from
there
>> inshallah but they should be in touch
with them you can leave out the house no
problem yes but be in touch with them
don't get angry inshallah Allah will
make their heart soft one time so as
long as you keep on talking to them keep
on giving literature keep on giving
books
>> you try your level best then you leave
it in the hands of Allah But don't give
up.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Okay. Most welcome. Yeah.